I'm Jerry Springer from my new show
judge Jerry and I hope you watch that
and I'm here to answer the internet and
the first question here is what is the
fiercest animal you think you could take
in a fight
well actually I once when I was mayor of
Cincinnati I fought a five hundred and
fifty pound bear named Victor and I
fought him in a ring for charity and it
would this is a true story we would
raise I think it was ten thousand
dollars for every minute that I could
stay in the ring with Victor the bear
and it was on live television on the six
o'clock news that the mayor of
Cincinnati was gonna be fighting this
bear I had agreed to it months earlier
because I thought you know it was for
charity and I wasn't thinking much about
it but as the day arrived I was really
frightened but it and so it's live
television so I step into the ring and
it's the mayor so you know I can't
chicken out there the whole city is
watching and the guy told me that when
you get into the ring with the bear you
know he he's not gonna hurt you just
gonna you know mess around a little bit
just don't touch his nose so the first
round for I'm dancing around I'm scared
but you know he's not he pushes once in
a while but it's not really hurting me
or anything and I'm starting to figure
because I'm a young guy then when I'm
mayor and so I'm thinking oh the macho
takes over I just made $10,000 round to
a minute twenty thousand how big this is
the last round how bad could this be I'm
dancing around I'll just touch his nose
for a second and I'm wearing glasses
there was a picture in the Cincinnati
Enquirer of me in the air horizontal it
knocked me and really hurt me and down I
go and he pounces on top of me
now I can't cry on the mayor but I would
really hurting and my glasses were
broken and I'm down on the ground and
they got to get the bear off me
that was when I fought Viktor the bear
1978 if you could pick one celebrity to
have your back in a bar fight who would
you pick
well I guess you know people would say
I'll pick the rock Mike Tyson Arnold
Schwarzenegger
you know Woody Allen would you rather
have a dick as your nose or a nose as
your dick well it would make it I really
wouldn't want to ever blow my nose would
you host the Jerry Springer Show if you
had to break up all the fights no no
first of all I wear rented suits I can't
afford to have them ripped up or
anything so no I wouldn't do would you
rather see your mom or sister on too hot
for TV that is sick do you think there
is more there are first of all the
grammar here is awful do you think there
are more porn stars or murderers in the
world
yeah well at some level most people at
some point in their life even in their
own bedroom with their own spouse or
porn stars so and not everyone's a
murderer
so yeah the more point I'm going point
to what is one rumor true or false you'd
want to spread about yourself that
Jennifer Lawrence is crazy about me
oh it's false but I wanted to spread a
rumor it's totally full she's got taste
this is it why would she be crazy about
me